comment je vais bien pouvoir fabriquer
une centrale nucléaire avec ça et
peut-être déjà vu des vidéos
j'achète de l'uranium sur internet c'est
cool hein t'as vu ça fait du bruit
qu'ils font peur mais derrière j'ai
l'impression qu'on peut pas faire grand
chose de plus j'ai enquêté avec mon ami
quantum et aujourd'hui on va faire un
truc d'agent secret un truc jamais vues
sur youtube vous emmène dans l'un des
endroits les plus sécurisés au monde un
site d'enrichissement d'uranium
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est vrai mais on va pas mettre ça on
est pas beau pour toi enfin quand on
parle d'uranium on dirait un peu vous
avez un truc dangereux genre l'uranium
mois on pense aux truffes vert
fluorescent qui va te donner huit bras
et 4 testicules si tu t'en approche et
on pose aussi et surtout vous fait que
s'est créée par l'homme c'est un truc et
un chimiques bien artificiel dégueulasse
sauf que l'uranium ça se trouve
vachement et surtout à l'état naturel
mais après c'est tellement facile à
trouver tu peux en trouver en 10
secondes même sur internet mais une
question demeure comment ce qu'on passe
du caillou à la centrale à l'énergie
finale qu'on va utiliser et bien c'est
là que le centre va nous apporter toutes
les réponses je vous propose d'enfiler
nos plus belles combinaisons jaunes
dégueulasse et de nous suivre dans la
centrale du tricastin
je sens prêt je veux toucher de rap il y
toucher du nucléaire
[Musique]
et
absolument rien
[Musique]
là dedans
plusieurs dizaines de tonnes d'uranium
enrichi et ce qui va se passer
un échantillon de 4 kg peut être élevée
que nous allons prélever et qu'on va
emmener au laboratoire pour analyse de
l'échantillon croyez-le ou non mais je
suis actuellement en train de porter
trois échantillons d'hexafluorure
d'uranium
c'est le composé qui sert à faire belle
et les combustibles des centrales
nucléaires en france et je tiens ça à
peu près 5 cm de mon visage mais tout va
bien fourni j'adore il panique derrière
celle là tout comme aux écoutes chez
c'est du travail de la détermination
c'est un peu la première étape avant
d'être gelée depuis dorman finalement
lassé mais pourquoi enrichir l'uranium
comme vous l'avez vu sur notre vidéo de
l'uranium y en a beaucoup même dans son
jardin le truc c'est que seul un certain
type d'uranium nous intéresse l'uranium
235 et il y en a pas beaucoup
0,7 pour cent du total de l'uranium sur
terre enrichir ses proches de l'uranium
essayé d'enlever l'uranium 235 de
l'isoler de le concentrer pour en avoir
un maximum si vous avez 100 % d'uranium
235 ce étrange re 1 ça fait de jolis
explosion
heureusement c'est interdit par toutes
les lois internationales par contre 3% 3
% c'est pas beaucoup 3% c'est stable et
ça va permettre de produire beaucoup
d'énergie pour plein de foyers ce que
vous connaissez vous c'est le premier
état de d'uranium l'uranium comme ceux
ci le métal c'est l'élément classique
celui que vous imaginez dans le tableau
périodique des éléments
l'uranium tout simple il va d'abord être
sous cette forme c'est ce qu'on appelle
le yellow cake cette espèce de poudre
jaune en tout surnom qui va être d'abord
dans cet état pour être transporté des
mines vers les premiers sites de
traitement
vient ensuite l'étape de
l'enrichissement de l'uranium l'uranium
on peut pas l'utiliser comme thème et
pour l'enrichir on va utiliser des
atomes de fluor
c'est à dire les mêmes at home continue
dans votre dentifrice on va donc lui
coller dans un premier temps quatre
atomes de fluor pour obtenir ce
tétrafluorure d'uranium d'une couleur un
peu un peu verte c'est la couleur qu'on
imagine des produits nucléaires et
ensuite dans un second temps c'est
d'ailleurs ce qui est principalement
fait sur ce site on l'enrichît une
seconde fois en y rajoutant à nouveau
deux atomes de fluor pour obtenir de
l'hexafluorure d'uranium
alors évidemment on vous en doutez c'est
un faux anti tueur production parce
qu'ici c'était un vrai jeu sera en grand
danger étant donné que ce produit est
très corrosif et radioactifs
hexafluorure d'uranium retenez bien ce
nom c'est la matière la plus importante
pour l'enrichissement
ça permet de transformer l'uranium qui
est remis talent ça lourd en un gaz et
ce à très faible température 64° et vu
que c'est gazeux c'est plus facile de
séparer les différents types d'uranium
c'est aussi une question de sécurité
parce que si le gaz s'échappe dans l'air
à l'uranium on retombe directement au
sol
c'est donc plus sécurisé et c'est pour
ça qu'on le transporte et qu'on le vend
comme ça à l'international alors
tellement nabili tout les gens là qui
était contenu qui était né de l'idée
dont on a vu qu'il y avait quasiment
rien de la coupe veut l'emporter parce
que j'entendais ya mon rappelle qu' un
couple craque médias gasquet montre un
peu le champ en milieu de grille aux
radios qui donc est ce qu'on va faire du
coup on pas s'approcher d'un dea
[Musique]
en montrant cette vidéo à mes amis j'ai
eu des mais là tu fous mais qu'est-ce
que ça fout dehors les bidons sont
blindées enfermé dans un sarcophage
à l'intérieur la matière est solide sans
fuite possible et surtout c'est pas très
radioactifs en fait on avait poussé la
machine à fond comme vous voyez sur la
vidéo les rayonnements sont deux très
courtes distances et faut vraiment s'y
coller pour que ça crie alors à ce
moment-là on voulait voir l' usine qui
permet d'enrichir l'uranium savez c'est
immense tube qu'on voit sur les photos
rousset des grosses turbines ou home et
l'hexafluorure d'uranium et chaque tube
va filtrer de plus en plus le radium
pour avoir nos 3 % de concentration
lusinchi fait ça les toutes nouvelles
c'est georges besse 2 et malheureusement
pouvait pas la visiter c'est top secret
mais s'il ya eu 1 2 il y a eu un numero
uno georges besse 1 c'est l'ancienne
usine et l on a pu la visiter en urbex
en exploration n'a pu se faufiler là
dedans et c'était très beau hockey laval
entre là dans la partie il y avait tous
les anciens jeux les anciennes machines
énormes et d'après ce qui est écrit sur
la porte
les deux pour ta vidéo
ok par contre j'ai entendu un bruit
alors qu'on met tout seul
[Musique]
que quatre ans
ici il régnait une chaleur infernale des
centaines de degrés dans lequel des
hommes et des femmes travaillent et une
usine grandiose mais qui va bientôt
disparaître
elle a fait son temps et elle sera
bientôt détruite on a peut-être été
parmi les derniers à avoir ça sur terre
coucou alors c'est vrai que la
suppression sera courte mais on est dans
un endroit assez exceptionnel la taille
des machines qui sont au dessus nous ce
qu'on a vu tout à l'heure quand on était
au dessus sur la vitre et menant à
redescendre un peu lentement
c'est vraiment très très très très ouf
si c'est vraiment enfin six et
abandonner que fins abandonné c'est plus
utilisé que depuis 2012 mais ça a été
construit à partir de 70 et il a fait
tomber en ce moment historique qui pèse
là sur toutes les machines
est-ce que je lâche un dab un des menus
clairs le dit mais c'est vrai qu'on soit
que le fait qu'on soit tous seuls
entièrement dans dans toute leur ca la
science et ça donne vraiment à côté un
peu mystique à l'endroit c'est c'est
très bizarre
bon bonne nouvelle c'est que mon
deuxième être n'a pas l'air de de
relever que ce soir je repars donc
normalement on n'a pas notre numéro
seront n'ont toujours pas donc on n'est
toujours pas contaminer donc on va
continuer à chercher des moyens de se
faire contaminer
on dirait un gland en fait non un peu à
part un peu un gland après ça et malgré
le vent ultra violent on a pu visiter un
endroit qui me fascine
ok bon derrière nous on a les deux
fameux énormissime tours
aéroréfrigérantes
c'est vous savez le presque le symbole
les tours symboles des centrales
nucléaires et ce qui va se passer mais
c'est qu'on va aller dedans et on va
essayer de faire voler un drone s'est
pas déjà et fantômes 3 ce que chillingo
gros tu fais le boulot
oh la la c'est tellement bon monsieur
et c'est là toute la vie c'est david
lappartient ok mone si on peut monter sa
petite échelle noir pouvoir pour faire
décoller le drone si on fait des clubs
en fait on a un drone qui est super
légers super fragile dans paraître vu
qu'il ya énormément de mistral dehors le
mistral s'engouffre par dessous dans la
tour et du coup ça fait un cours en
montant à l'aide qu'on a peur c'est un
drone qui déjà de lui n'est pas à nous
et qui de 2 et super légers on a peur
que le drone s'envole et qu'on le perde
complètement donc d'un côté on est
tellement excité qu'on veut on veut des
plans de cet endroit c'était super vous
même temps c'est pas si on
on risque le drone ya donc ouais
effectivement il ya un truc important
c'est que comme vous voyez c'est ici
qu'on mettait le réacteur nucléaire non
j'rigole criant n'a pas en fait c'était
juste pour l'eau c'est quand l'eau à la
vapeur elle se refroidit c'est comme ça
la retombée elle pouvait être
réutilisées donc en fait qu'est-ce qu'il
sort des tours de l'eau alors comme ça
je pensais vraiment que j'allais
rencontrer des scientifiques fous et des
militaires une trame nerfs alors pour
les militaires peut-être mais en ce
qu'il s'agit des scientifiques et des
opérateurs il s'agit alors tout ça
c'était des crèmes des gens qui étaient
fascinés par leur métier mais ça fait
toujours plaisir à voir
alors quand je suis arrivé là bas j'ai
plein de questions du plein de réponses
comptant plus de questions je sais plus
où moins fabriquer marty centrales
nucléaires la maison tout évidemment
poussé long il ya beaucoup de chimie
vous citez vous quelques petites vidéos
en tuto il ya un mètre sur internet qui
est allé très loin quasiment à l'exacte
jours durant
un garçon trouve je voulais aussi
remercier aura nos pour nous avoir aidés
sur cette vidéo
ils ont été très cool ils ont laissé
carte blanche mais en tout cas on a pu
faire beaucoup de choses très étonné
mais agréablement surpris vous le 6
remercier tous les hommes et les femmes
qui nous ont accueillis sur leur lieu de
travail ils vont pas souvent des buteurs
c'est pas genre van doren ya des bêtes
et des caméras cublac souvent merci à
eux
j'espère avoir aiguisé votre curiosité
d'avoir montré des trucs qu'on voit pas
souvent sur youtube et surtout vous
avoir donné envie d'explorer ce monde
je vous remercie encore m'avoir donné la
possibilité de aller mais vu qu'on a
fini d'être journée tout en fait on a
décidé d'aller à la ferme aux crocodiles
de pierrelatte
on va voir des crocodiles
dans la même journée j'aurais quand même
été à côté d'uranium radioactif
dangereux et de piranhas je pensais pas
beaucoup quand sur terre qui peut le
dire cette phrase